this is a pig you're handed me a pig
that producer here wants to try to make
me smile
good luck god this is like that game I
played as a kid like I love you honey
but I just can't smile I smiled once I
hated it
I'm already smiling so I don't think I'm
gonna be too good at this from here on
out I'm about to press play and I'm not
gonna smile and I am NOT going to smile
[Music]
this is adorable I actually feel like
dirty that I wasn't able to express
those emotions like if they have blue
balls for your heart I've got blue balls
of the heart very cute
didn't smile nailed it this better not
be a clown hey man how's it going what's
your name blank and what's your name
also blank oh man you got me remember
I'm not angry I'm just trying not to
smile how many software engineers does
it take to install a light bulb No zero
cuz its hardware you don't get that one
nope
I don't know which house is another
house I don't know what's happening
[Music]
does this happened with every person
how's your day he just left me thank you
for the hug
no it's very nice for you of course the
kid's gonna make me smile and understand
his jokes but still wanted to laugh at
his jokes Eric I'm expecting more from
you man
[Music]
I will never smile I have never smiled
what is that what does that sound
it's little snout is tiny can someone
hold his face so I can look at his face
Sorby who's first oh he's pooping can i
scratch and you are you like a butt
scratch the by screech yeah dad damn
again Eric trying like hahaha something
on PE course I'm gonna smile it's
adorable little baby pig has shat all
over my arm when I scratched your butt
her leg did this thing cute little
puppies and then adorable little kids
with hugs I'm gonna you know little
teacup pig can't get me but wants
something she's in front of me just
laughs life is too short
come here come here lady has he pooped
on everyone just me Eric you got me to
smile you did it you mad genius
nope nope that's not foot nope that's
not food there we go
there we go